foreign
[Music]
you've already seen superheroes break
the fourth wall oh hello balance their
law practice with B downs
and explore what goes on when the
costumes come off
but the mcu's newest hero is here to
remind us she's been doing all of that
since 1995. I mean it's kind of stale
now but she was first
She-Hulk attorney at law
meet Jennifer Waters a milestone in
representation for public servants who
move on to more lucrative corporate gigs
after that time she went full Targaryen
with her cousin she'll become She-Hulk
a lawyer committed to greenwashing her
firm's New Image but don't worry if
you're not into those lawyer shows
it's mostly about this beautiful Rich
woman's impossible quest to find a good
man ew just imagine if Tatiana's Lonnie
could cover your Wren and turn into a
harder version of herself it's gross
just to think about it
thrill as She-Hulk fights the half of
humanity Thanos forgot to warn you about
man there's a hot chick over there I'm
gonna go talk to it as she's attacked by
online misogynists they're just trolls
dating abdinguses what a specimen how
much can you deadlift or those nice guys
who you just know are full of it yes I
feel I have been rehabilitated
emotionally physically metaphysically
spiritually I see you Tim Roth can't lie
to me but after seven episodes of
foreplay we finally get to meet one of
the good ones Daredevil I'm here Charlie
Cox returns as the hero everyone wants
in their hallway
he's got the look he's got the skills
and the men without fear is clearly not
afraid of keeping his identity Secret at
all
Mr patilio what kind of fuel did you use
in your boosters uh you're using your
powers in court bro chill I have to go
with something that's just uh come up
with work urgent legal business in the
middle of the night across the country
from your practice Emperor insanity is
Mercy but it's not a bad strategy
an angle this more is a form of
traumatic expression theater undiagnosed
PTSD dude wait until the costume is off
to give legal advice it's a tell
legit won't Hulk smash the patriarchy
alone there's Nikki her work bestie and
actual bestie because no one in the MCU
has friends outside of their job Lulu
who got screamed at by Freddy Krueger
and sewn into the pants of the big
Charlie Brown and Titania a superhero
addicted to social media played by a
supermodel addicted to social media who
goes after super villains addicted to
social media oh plus we get a little
long as a treat
want a gripping legal trauma that relies
on the lawyer's Brilliant Minds in the
quirks of the American court system
Better Call Saul but if you're looking
for a show with more of an Ace Attorney
approach
[Music]
then better send Jen where the cases
feel made up on the Fly you can't own
magic you can't trademark a spirit
resolve in an instant the defendant is
absolved of all liability I'm dismissing
this case and the judges don't give a
[ __ ] because according to the showrunner
running a good lawyer show is hard you
couldn't have I don't know hired writers
from like good legal shows just spitball
in here oh is that how it works your
honor yeah
so do what everyone else does these days
and make up your mind to love or hate
this show before you even see it that
isn't as bad as the review bombers made
it out to be but isn't good enough to
really defend in court because at the
end of the day wait wait hold up this is
already the outro what about the
twerking scene the planet Hulk tease no
no no no we're not done yet I demand to
talk to whoever writes this crap
no not those idiots I want to talk to
their boss the YouTube algorithm
yes epic voice guy why are we ending the
trailer here data indicates you retain
more viewers when your videos are
between five and seven minutes in length
well what if there's more to say viewers
will just fast forward to the park with
the funny names okay that sucks put a
lot of thought into everything except
that part anything we could do to change
our minds be more hateful data indicates
hate is great for views clearly but
we're honest trailers if something's
good we say it's good mid bad bad Etc
it's my gift and my curse recalculating
have you considered trying to become a
wife guy and then cheat on her way okay
forget it we're done here
story
female lawyer
thickness for the prosecution my best
friend's hearing Bruce Brunner bruh Tiny
Tim and the Abominable grow man the goop
troop Hulk smash that like button The
Man Without Shame
pug life Stefan or Kell the try guy you
know the one too long thanks for
everything Jen Walters and Madison is
with two ends one why but it's not where
you think
m-a-d-y-s-m-a-d-i-i-s m-i-d I really
don't know where the Y goes it's not
what I thought
law and ogre super Victims Unit
Marvel movies all end the same way throw
a bunch of plot and flash at the
audience in the climax no the big
showdowns are just for the movies the
show's only in an avoid outside space
and time where the thing gets explained
to you by a god see you're doing it
right now
no tears please it's a waste of good
suffering
go local sports team
I'm sorry your name is Karen
I am he who remembers the ancient of
Rights and its epic voice thank you very
much